the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
inference again this was just an
overview of what you can do in Bayesian
inference and last time we started
defining what's called Jeffrey's priors
right so when you do Bayesian inference
you have to introduce a prior on your
parameter and we said that usually it's
something that encodes your domain
knowledge about where the parameter
could be but there's also some
principled way to do it if you want to
do Bayesian inference without really
having to think about it and for example
one of the natural priors were those non
informative priors right if you're on a
compact set it's a uniform prior over
this set if you're on an infinite set
you can still think of taking the old
ones prior and that's called and
something probably that's always equal
to one and that's an improper prior if
you're an infinite set and/or
proportional to one and so another
project you can think of in the case
where you have a Fisher information
which is well defined is something
called Jeffrey's prior and this prior is
a prior which is proportional to square
root of the determinant of the Fisher
information matrix and if you just have
if you're in one dimension it's
basically proportional to square root of
the Fisher information coefficient which
we know for example as the synthetic
variance at this of the maximum
likelihood estimator and and it turns
out that it's basically so square root
of this thing is basically 1 over the
standard deviation of the maximum
likelihood estimator and so you can
compute this right so you can compute
for the maximum likelihood estimator we
know that the variance is going to be P
1 minus P in the in the Bernoulli
statistical experiment so you get this 1
over square root of this thing
and for example in the Gaussian setting
you actually have the Fisher information
even in the multivariate one is actually
going to be something like the identity
matrix so this is proportional to one
it's the improper prior that you get in
this case okay meaning that for the
Gaussian setting no no place where you
Center your Gaussian is actually better
than any other alright so we basically
left on this slide where we saw that
Jeffrey's priors satisfy a repair
motorization they're invariant by from
transformation of your parameter which
is a desirable property and and they say
in a way it says that well if I have my
prior on theta and then I certainly
decide that theta is not the parameter I
want to use to parameterize my problem
actually what I want is five theta for
thing for example as theta being the
mean of a Gaussian and Phi of theta as
being this mean to the cube okay this is
a one-to-one map Phi right so for
example if I want to go from theta
choose theta cube and now I decide that
this is the actual parameter that I want
well then it means that on this
parameter my original prior is going to
induce another prior and here it says
well this prior is actually also
Jeffrey's prior okay so it's essentially
telling you that for this new
parameterization if you take Jeffrey's
prior then you actually go back to
having exactly something that's of the
form skirt of determinate of the Fisher
information but this thing with respect
to your new parameter ization all right
and so why is this true well it's just
this change of variable theorem right so
it's essentially telling you that if you
call let's call P well let's call P
tilde of Geeta prior over ETA and you
have PI's of theta as the prior of theta
then just by since ETA is of the form
Phi of theta just by change of variable
right so that's essentially a
probability result it says that PI tilde
of eta is equal to PI of ETA times D PI
of theta times D theta over D ETA and
sorry is that the one should I'm gonna
have to write it because I always forget
this so if I take a function okay so
what I want is to check
okay okay so I want a function of ETA
that I can put here and what I know is
that this is H of Phi of theta
all right so sorry eta is five data
right yeah so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna do the change of variable theta is
Phi inverse so eta is Phi of theta which
means that D eta is equal to D twelve to
Phi prime of theta D theta so what I'm
gonna write this I'm gonna get integral
of H actually me write this as a
comfortable writing this as e with
respect to a tie of HIV time okay so
that's just it according to being drawn
from the prior and I want to write this
as the integral of H of ETA times some
function right so this is the integral
of H of Phi of theta phi of theta now
I'm gonna do my change of variable so
this is gonna be the integral of H of
theta and then Phi of Phi Theta is and
then prime of theta okay and so what is
pi of Phi Theta so this thing is
proportional so we're in say dimension
one so it's proportional of square root
of the Fisher information and the Fisher
information we know is the expectation
of the square of the derivative of the
log likelihood right so this is square
root of the expectation
d over the theta of log of well now I
need the density well let's just call it
log let's call it L of theta and I want
this to be taken at Phi inverse beta
squared and then what I pick up is the
so I'm going to put everything under the
square so I get Phi prime of theta
squared D theta ok so now I have the
expectation of a squared this does not
depend so this is sorry this is L of
theta this is the expectation of L of
theta and X right that's for some
variable and the expectation here is
with respect to X that's just the
definition of the feature information so
now I'm going to squeeze this guy into
the expectation it does not depend on X
it just acts as a constant and so what I
have now is that this is actually
proportional to the integral of H ETA
times the square root of the expectation
with respect to X of what well here I
have D over D theta of log of theta and
here this guy is really D ETA over D
theta right ok so now what I'm really
left by so I get D over D theta times
this sorry times D theta over D ETA
so that's just D over D ETA of log of
ETA
X
and then this guy is now becoming DITA
right okay so this was a mess this is a
complete mess because they actually want
to use fire should not actually
introduce fire at all I should just talk
about overdue data type of things and
then that would actually make my life so
much easier
okay I'm not going to spend more time on
this this is really just the idea right
you have square root of a square in
there and then when you do your change
your variable you just pick up a square
you just pick up something and here and
so you just move this thing in there you
get a square it goes inside the square
and so your derivative of the log
likelihood with the respective theta
becomes a derivative of the likelihood
respect to theta and that's just that's
the only thing that's happening here
I'm just being super sloppy for some
reason okay and then of course now what
you're left with is that this is really
just proportional well this is actually
equal everything is proportional but
this is equal to the Fisher information
tilde with respect to Chiquita now right
you're doing this with respect to ETA
and so that's a new that's your new
prior with respect to theta okay so one
thing that you want to do once you have
so remember when you actually compute
your your posterior right rather than
having so you start with a prior and you
have some observations let's say x1 to
xn when you do Bayesian inference rather
than spitting out just some theta hat
which is an estimator for theta you
actually spit out an entire posterior
distribution PI of theta given X 1 xn ok
so there's an entire distribution on the
candidates theta and you can actually
use this to perform inference rather
than just having one number okay and so
you could actually build confidence
regions from this thing okay and so a a
Bayesian
confidence interval so if your set of
parameters is included in the real line
then you can actually it's not even it's
not even guaranteed to be to be an
interval so let me call it a confidence
region so a bayesian confidence region
okay so it's just a random subspace so
let's call it R is included in theta and
when you had the deterministic one we
had a definition which was with respect
to the randomness of the data right
that's how you actually had a random
subset you had a random confidence
interval here it's actually conditioned
on the data but with respect to the
randomness that you actually get from
your posterior distribution
okay so such that the probability that
your theta belongs to this confidence
region given X 1 xn and say at least 1
minus alpha let's just take it equal to
1 minus alpha okay so that's a
confidence region at lab at level 1
minus alpha okay so that's one way so
why would you actually I when I actually
implement Bayesian inference I'm
actually spinning out an entire
distribution I need to summarize this
this thing to communicate it right I
cannot just say this is this entire
function I want to know where are the
regions of high probability where my
parameter is supposed to be and so here
when I have this thing what I actually
want to have is something that says well
I want to summarize this thing into some
subset of the real line in which I'm
sure that the area under the curve here
of my posterior is actually 1 minus
alpha and there's many ways to do this
right so one way to do this
is to look at level sets and so rather
than actually so let's say my my
posterior looks like this I know for
example if I have a Gaussian
distribution I can actually take my
posterior to be my posterior is actually
going to be Gaussian and what I can do
is to try to cut it here on the y axis
so that now the area under the curve
when I cut here is actually 1 minus
alpha okay so I have some threshold tau
if tau goes to plus infinity then I'm
gonna have that this area under the
curve here is going to
well no no so the air end of the curve
when Tao is going to plus infinity think
of the small the when Tao is just like
right here so this is actually going to
zero right and so I start here and then
I start going down and down and down and
down until I actually get something
which is going down to one plus alpha
but if tau is going down to zero then my
area under the curve is going to if tau
is here I'm cutting nowhere and so I'm
getting one right agree
think of when tau is very close to zero
I'm cutting as very far here and so I'm
getting some area under the curve which
is almost everything and so it's going
to one iced out going down to zero yeah
no it does not I mean so this is a
picture this picture so those two things
work for all of them right but when you
have a bino model actually this is
actually when things start to become
interesting right so when we had when we
built a frequentist confidence interval
it was always of the form x-bar plus or
minus something but now if I start to
have a posterior that looks like this
I'm gonna start cutting off I'm gonna
have to I mean my confidence region is
going to be the union of those two
things right and it really reflects the
fact that there's this bimodal thing
it's gonna say well with higher
probability I'm actually going to be
either here or here now the meaning here
of a bayesian Conference region and a
confidence interval or completely
distinct notions right
and it's actually I'm gonna work out an
example with you so that we can actually
see that sometimes I mean both of them
actually you can come up with some crazy
paradoxes so since we don't have that
much time I will actually talk to you
about why in some instances it's
actually a good idea to think of
Bayesian confidence intervals rather
than frequentist ones so before I go
into more details about what those
Bayesian confidence intervals are let's
remind ourselves what is it
mean do you have a frequentist
confidence interval right so okay so
when I have a frequentist point
confidence interval let's say something
like X bar and it's minus 1.96 the Sigma
over root N and X Bar n plus 1 point 9 6
Sigma over ribbon right so that's the
confidence interval that you get for the
mean of some Gaussian with known
variants to be equal to Sigma square ok
so what we know is that the meaning of
this is the probability that theta
belongs to this is equal to 95 percent
right and this more general you can
think of being Q alpha over 2 and when
you're gonna get is 1 minus alpha here
okay so what does it mean here well it
means it looks very much like what we
have here except that we're not
conditioning on X 1 xn and we should not
because there was a question like that
in the midterm if I condition on X 1 X
and this probability is either 0 or 1
okay because once I condition so here
this probability actually here is with
respect to the randomness in X 1 xn so
if I condition let's call this thing our
frack for frequent test well given X 1
xn and actually at only 2 nu X 1 xn
really what I need to know is what xn
bar is well this thing now is what it's
1 if theta is in R and it's 0 if theta
is not in our right that's all there is
this is a deterministic confidence
interval once I condition on X M 1 X n
so I have a number the average is maybe
3 and so I get 3 either theta is between
3 minus 0.5 or in 3 point plus 0.5 or
it's not and
there's basically I mean I read it as
probability but it's really not a
probabilistic thing minutes either is
sure or not agreed so what does it mean
to have a frequentist confidence
interval and means that if I were so and
here it was where the word frequentist
comes from it says that if I repeat this
experiment over and over meaning that on
Monday I could like the sample of size N
and I build a confidence interval and
then on Tuesday I collect another sample
of size N and I build a confidence
interval and on Wednesday I do this
again and again what's gonna happen is
the following I'm gonna have my truth
theta that lives here and then on Monday
this is the confidence interval that I
build okay so this is the real line the
truth theta is here and this is the
comfortable I build on Monday
all right so X bar was here and this is
my confidence interval on Tuesday I
built this confidence interval maybe
thanks bar was closer to theta a bit
smaller but then on Wednesday I built
this confidence interval I'm not here
it's not in there and that's this case
right it happens that it's just not in
there and then on Thursday I build
another one I almost miss it but I'm in
there etc maybe here I miss again and so
what it means to have a confidence
interval so what does it mean to have a
confidence interval at 95% yeah so it
means that if I repeat this the
frequency of times hence the word
frequentist at which I'm actually going
to overlap that I'm actually going to
contain theta should be 95% that's what
frequencies means so it's just a matter
of life trusting that so on one given
thing one given realization of your data
it's not telling you anything right
there is there or not so it's not really
something that's actually something that
assesses the confidence of your decision
such as theta is in there or not it's
something that assesses the confidence
you have in the method that you're using
if you were to repeat it over and again
would be the same thing
would be 95% of the time correct right
so for example we know that we could
build a test right so it's pretty clear
that you can actually build a test for
whether theta is equal to theta naught
or not equal to theta or not by just
checking whether theta naught is in a
confidence interval or not and what it
means is that if you actually are doing
those tests at 90 at 5% then it means
that 5% of the time you should do this
over and again 5% of the time you're
gonna be wrong
I mentioned my wife does come does
market research and she does maybe I
don't know a hundred thousand tests a
year and if they do all of them at 1%
then it means that 1% of the time which
is a lot of time right when you do a
hundred thousand a year it's 1,000 of
them are actually wrong I mean they're
she's actually you know hedging against
the fact that 1% of them are going to be
wrong that's the thousand of them that
are gonna be wrong just like if you do
this a hundred thousand times at 95%
five thousand of those guys are actually
not gonna be the correct ones okay so I
mean it's kind of scary but that's the
way it is so that's what the frequentist
interpretation of this is now as I
mentioned when we started this Bayesian
chapter I said Bayesian statistics sort
of converge to I mean Bayesian decisions
and Bayesian methods sort of converged
to frequentist methods they sort of when
the sample size is large enough they
sort of lead to the same decisions and
in general there need not be the same
but they tend to actually when the
sample size is large enough to have the
same behavior think about for example
the posterior that you have when you
have in the gaussian case right we said
that in the gaussian case what you're
gonna see is that it's as if you had an
extra observation which was essentially
given by your prior okay and and now
it's the the what's gonna happen is that
when the this just one observation among
n plus one it's really going to be truly
you know drawn and you won't see it when
the sample size grows large
so Bayesian methods are particularly
useful when you have a small sample size
and when you have a small sample size
you can actually the effect of the prior
is going to be bigger but most
importantly you're not going to have to
repeat this thing
and again and you're gonna have a
meaning you're gonna have to have
something that has a meaning for this
particular data set that you have right
when I said that the probability that
theta belongs to R and here I'm going to
specify the fact that it's a Bayesian
confidence region like this one this is
actually conditionally on the data that
you've collected it says given this data
given the points that you have just put
in some numbers if you want in there
it's actually telling you the
probability that theta belongs to this
Bayesian thing to this Bayesian
confidence region here since I've
conditioned on X 1 X n this probability
is really just with respect to theta
drawn from the prior right and so now it
has a slightly different meaning is just
telling you that when I it's really
making a statement about where the
regions of high probability of your
posterior are now why is that useful
well there was actually there's actually
an interesting story that goes behind
Bayesian methods the anybody knows the
the story of the USS scorpion do you
know this the story so that was a
American vessel that disappeared I think
he was like close to Bermuda or
something but you know you can tell the
story the malaysian airlines'
except that i don't think it's such a
successful story but the idea was
essentially we're trying to find where
this thing happened and of course you
don't have this is a one-time thing you
actually have you need something that
works once it's something that works for
this particular vessel and you don't
care if you go to the navy and you tell
them well you know here's the method and
for ninety five out of a hundred vessels
that you're gonna lose we're gonna be
able to find it and and they want this
to work for this particular one and so
they were looking and they were you know
they were diving in different places and
and suddenly they brought in this guy I
forget his name I mean there's a whole
story about this on Wikipedia and he
started collecting the data that they
had from different dives and maybe from
currents and it started to put
everything and he said okay what is the
posterior distribution of the location
of the vessel given all the things that
I've seen and what are you have you seen
well you've seen that
it's not here it's not there and it's
not there and you've also seen that the
currents are going that way and the wind
we're going that way and you can
actually put some model and try to
understand this now given this for this
particular data that you have you can
actually think of having a
two-dimensional density that tells you
where it's more likely then that the
vessel is and where are you going to be
looking for well if it's a multi-modal
distribution you're just gonna go to the
highest mode first because that's where
it's the most likely to be and maybe
it's not there so you're just gonna
update your posterior based on the fact
that it's not there and do it again
and actually after - two dives I think
he actually found the thing and that's
exactly where Bayesian statistics start
to kick in because you put a lot of
knowledge into your into your model but
you also can actually factor in a bunch
of information right the model you had
to build a model that was actually
taking into account currents and and and
when and what you can't have as a
guarantee is that when you talk about
the probability that this vessel is you
know in this location given what you've
observed in the past it actually has
some sense whereas if you were to use a
a frequentist approach then there's no
probability either it's underneath this
position or it's not right so that's
actually where it it start to make sense
and so you can actually build this and
there's actually a lot of methods that
are based on you know for search that
are based on Bayesian methods I think
for example the Higgs boson which based
on a lot of Bayesian methods because
this is something you need to find once
right I mean there was a lot of prior
that has to be built in okay so now you
build this confidence interval and the
nicest way to do it is to use level sets
but again just like for gaussians right
I mean if I had even in the in the even
in the Gaussian case I decided to go at
X bar plus or minus something but I
could go at like something that's
completely asymmetric so what's
happening is that tier this method
guarantees that you're gonna have the
narrow as possible confidence intervals
that's essentially what it's telling you
okay because every time I'm choosing a
point starting from here I'm actually
putting as much area under the curve as
I can all right
so so those are called Bayesian
confessional oh yeah and I promise you
that we're gonna work on some example
that actually sort of sort of give the
meeting to what I just told you
with like actual numbers so this is
something that's taken from Worcester
mins book and that's also it's all it's
coming from a paper from stats paper
from walpert and I don't know who from
the 80s and essentially this is how it
works
so observe assume that you have N equals
two observations and you have y1 so
those observations are y1 let no sorry
let's call them x1 which is theta plus
epsilon 1 and X 2 which is theta plus
epsilon 2 or epsilon 1 and epsilon 2 are
iid and the probability that epsilon I
is equal to plus 1 is equal to the
probability that X 1 I is equal to minus
1 is equal to 1/2 okay so it's just the
uniform sign plus minus 1 okay now let's
think about so you're trying to do some
inference on theta maybe you actually
want to find some inference on theta
that's actually based on and that's
based only on the epsilon x1 and x2 okay
so I'm gonna actually build a confidence
interval but what I really want to build
is a is but let's start thinking about
how I would find an estimator for those
two things well what values am I going
to be getting right so I'm gonna get
either theta plus 1 or theta minus 1 and
actually I can get basically four
different observations right sorry four
different pairs of observations
plus plus theta minus Oh agreed
those are the four possible observations
that I can get agree either they're both
equal to plus one
the both equal to minus one or one of
the two is equal to plus one the other
one to minus one for the Epsilon's okay
so the four observations I can get so in
particular if they take the same value
you know it's it's either theta plus 1
or theta minus 1 and if they take a
different value I know one of them is
theta plus one and one is actually theta
minus one so in particular if I take the
average of those two guys when they take
different values I know I'm actually
getting clear too right so let's build a
confidence region okay so I'm actually
going to take a conference region which
is just a singleton and I'm gonna say
the following
well if x1 is equal to x2 I'm just gonna
take x1 minus 1 okay so I'm just saying
well I'm never gonna be able to resolve
whether it's plus 1 or minus 1 that
actually gives me the best one so I'm
just gonna take a dive and say well it's
just plus 1 okay and then if they're
different then here I can do much better
I'm gonna actually just take the average
okay now what I claim is that this is a
confidence region and by default when I
don't mention it this is a frequentist
confidence region at level 75 percent
okay so let's just check that to check
that this is correct I need to check
that the probability under the
realization of x1 and x2 that theta
belongs is one of those two guys is
actually equal to point 75
yes
it's just a frequencies confidence
interval that need not it does not need
to be an interval actually in this case
it's gonna be an interval but that's
just what it means
yeah Region four Bayesian was just
because I mean the confidence intervals
when we're frequentist we tend to make
them intervals by because we want but
when your vision you're doing this
levels that thing you cannot really
guarantee unless it's unimodal it's
gonna be an integral so region is just a
way to not have to say interval in case
it's not okay so I have this distinct so
what I need to check is the probability
that theta is in one of those two things
right so what I need to find is the
probability of theta is in in well X 1
minus 1 and X 1 is not equal to X 2 and
those are disjoint events is the plus
the probability of theta is in X 1 plus
X 2 over 2 and X 1 sorry that's equal
that's different okay and okay just
before we actually finish the
computation why do I have 75% so
refreshed percent is 3/4 so it means
that we have four cases and essentially
I did not account for one case and it's
true I did not account for this case
when the both of the epsilon i's are
equal to minus 1 right so this is
essentially the one I'm not gonna be
able to account for and so we'll see
that in a second so in this case we know
that everything goes great right so in
this case this is okay well that's just
right
let's start from the first line so the
first line is the probability that theta
is equal to X 1 minus 1 and those two
are equal so this is the probability
that theta is equal to well this is what
this is theta plus epsilon 1 minus 1 and
epsilon 1 is equal to epsilon 2
right because I can remove the theta
from here and I can actually remove the
theta from here so that this guy here is
just epsilon one is equal to one so when
I intersect with this guy it's actually
the same thing as epsilon 1 is equal to
one as well epsilon 2 is equal to 1 is 1
okay so this first thing is actually
equal to the probability that epsilon 1
is equal to 1 and epsilon 2 is equal to
1 which is equal to what we have 1/4
right so that's just the first case over
there they're independent now I still
need to do the second one so this case
is what well when those things are equal
X 1 plus X 2 over 2 is what well I get
theta plus theta over 2 so that's just
equal to the probability that epsilon 1
plus epsilon 2 over 2 is equal to 0 and
epsilon 1 is different from epsilon 2
agreed I just removed the Thetas from
these equations because I can't they're
just on both sides every time ok and so
that means what that means that the
second part so this thing is actually
equal to 1/4 plus the probability at
epsilon 1 and epsilon 2 over 2 is equal
to 0 I can remove the 2 so this is just
the probably at 1 is 1 and the other one
is minus 1 right
so that's equal to the probability that
epsilon 1 is equal to 1 and epsilon 2 is
equal to minus 1 plus the probability
that epsilon 1 is equal to minus 1 and
epsilon 2 is equal to plus 1 ok because
they're disjoint events so I can break
them into the sum of the two and each of
those guy is also one of the you know
atomic part of it right one of the basic
things and so each of those guys has
probability 1/4 and so here we can
really see that we accounted for
everything except for the case when
epsilon 1 was equal to minus 1 and
epsilon 2 is equal to minus 1 so this is
1/4 this is 1/4 so the whole thing is
equal to 3/4 so now what we have is that
the probability that epsilon 1
is in so the probability that theta
belongs to this conference region is
equal to 3/4 and that's very nice and
you know but the thing is some people
are sort of I mean it's not super nice
to be able to say this because in a way
I know that if I observe X 1 and X 2
that are different I know for sure that
X is that theta that I actually got the
right data right that this confidence
interval is actually happening at a with
probability 1 and the problem is that I
do not know I cannot make this precise
with the notion of frequentist
confidence intervals okay because
frequencies conference intervals have to
account for the fact that in the future
it might not be the case that x1 and x2
are different so Bayesian confidence
regions by definition well they're all
gone but they're conditioned on the data
that I have and so that's what I want I
want to be able to make a statement
conditionally on the on the data that I
have okay so if I want to be able to
make this statement I'm gonna have to
put if I want to build a Bayesian
confidence region I'm gonna have to put
a prior on theta so without loss of
generality I mean maybe with but let's
say assume that pi is a prior on theta
and let's assume that pi of j is
strictly positive for all integers J
equals say 0 well actually for all J in
the integers ok positive or negative ok
so that's a pretty weak assumption on my
prior I'm just saying I'm just assuming
that theta is some integer and now let's
build our confidence or a Bayesian
confidence region well if I want to
build a Bayesian confidence region I
need to understand what my posterior is
gonna be okay and if I want to
understand what my posterior is gonna be
I actually need to build
a likelihood right so we know that it's
the product of the likelihood and of the
prior / okay so so what is my likelihood
right so my likelihood is the
probability of x1 x2 given theta right
that's what the likelihood should be and
[Music]
now let's say that actually just to make
things a little simpler let us assume
that X 1 is equal to I don't know 5 and
X 2 is equal to 7
okay so this is exactly I'm not going to
take the case where they're actually
equal to each other because they know
that in this case x1 and x2 are
different I know I'm gonna actually nail
exactly what data is by looking at the
average of those guys right here it must
be that theta is equal to 0 to 6 so what
I want is to compute the likelihood at 5
& 7
okay what is this likelihood well if
theta is equal to 6 that's just the
probability that I observe 5 & 7 right
so what is the probability observe 5 & 7
yeah one that's 1/4 right is the
probability I have minus 1 on the first
on the for the first epsilon 1 right so
this is an if then a 6 this is the
probability that epsilon 1 is equal to
plus one a to minus 1 and epsilon 2 is
equal to plus 1 which is equal to 1/4 so
this probability is 1/4 if theta is
different from 6 what is this
probability so if theta is different
from 6 since we know that we've only
loaded the integers right so theta has
to be another integer what is the
probability that I see 5 and 7 0 so
that's my likelihood and if I want to
know what my posterior is well it's just
pi of theta times P of 5 6 given theta
divided by the sum over all cheese say
in Z all right so now I just need to
normalize this thing so of PI of T P of
5 6 given T agree that's just the
definition of the posterior but when I
sum these guys there's only one that
counts because for those things we know
that this is actually equal to 0 for
every T except for when T is equal to 6
so this entire sum here is actually
equal to PI of 6 times P of 5 6
sorry 5 7 of 5 7
given that I see given that theta is
equal to 6 which we know is equal to 1/4
and I did not tell you what PI of 6 was
right
but it's the same thing here the
posterior foresee any theater that's not
six is actually gonna be this guy is
going to be equal to zero so I really
don't care what this guy is so what it
means is that my posterior becomes what
it becomes so posterior PI of theta
given five and seven is equal to well
when theta is equal to is not equal to 6
this is actually 0 so we regardless of
what I do here I get something which is
0 and if theta is equal to 6 what I get
is PI of 6 times P of 5 7 given 6 which
have just computed here which is 1/4
divided by PI of 6 the times 1/4 so it's
the ratio of two things that are
identical so I get 1 so now my posterior
tells me that given that I observe 5 and
7 the theta is giving me it has to be 1
with probability 6 with probability 1 so
now I sort of say that this thing here
so now I can act this is not something
that actually makes sense
when I talk about frequentist confidence
intervals I cannot really they don't
really make sense to talk about
confidence intervals given something and
so now given that I observed 5 and 7 I
know that the probability of data is
equal to 1 and in this sense the
Bayesian confidence interval is actually
more meaningful so one thing I want to
actually say about this Bayesian
confidence interval is that it's it's I
mean here it's equal to the value 1
right so it really encompasses the thing
that we want but the fact that we
actually computed it using the Bayesian
posterior and the Bayesian rule did not
really matter for this argument all I
just said it with it had a prior but
just what I want to illustrate is the
fact that we can actually give a meaning
to the probability of that theta is
equal to 6 given that I see 5 & 7
whereas we do not really in the other
cases and we don't have to be
particularly precise in the prior on
theta
to be able to give data this to give
this meeting okay all right so now as I
said I think the main power of Bayesian
inference is that it spits out the
posterior distribution and not just a
single number like frequentist would
give you then you know we can say
decorate our theta hat or point estimate
with maybe some confidence interval
maybe we can do a bunch of tests but at
the end of the day we just have
essentially one number all right and
maybe we can sort of understand what the
fluctuations of this number are in a
frequentist set up but but the Bayesian
framework is essentially giving you a
natural method and you can interpret it
in terms of the probabilities that are
associated to the prior but you can
actually also try to make some right so
a vision if you give me any prior you're
gonna actually build an estimator from
this fryer maybe from the posterior and
maybe it's gonna have some frequencies
properties and that's what's really nice
about visions is that you can actually
try to give some frequencies properties
of Bayesian with methods that are built
using Bayesian methodology but you
cannot really go the other way around if
I give you a frequencies methodology how
are you gonna say something about the
fact that you know the Prai there's a
prior going on etc and so this is
actually one of the things there's
actually some research that's going on
for this they call it a Bayesian a
posterior concentration and one of the
things so there's something called the
Bernstein von Mises theorem and those
are class of theorems and those are
essentially methods that tell you well
if I actually run a Bayesian method and
I look at the posterior that I get right
it's gonna be something like this but
now I try to study this in a frequentist
point of view there's actually a true
parameter theta somewhere the true one
there's no prior for this guy this is
just one fixed number is it true that as
my sample size is going to go to
infinity then this thing is going to
concentrate around theta and the rate of
concentration of this thing the size of
this with the standard deviation of this
thing is something that should decay
maybe like 1 over square root of N or
something like this and the rate of
posterior concentration
when you characterize it is called the
Bernstein when mesosphere and so people
are looking at this in some
nonparametric cases you can do it in
pretty much everything we've been doing
before right you can do it for you know
nonparametric regression estimation or
density estimation you can do it for of
course you can do it for sparse
estimation if you want okay so you can
actually compute the posterior and and
and and and and and yeah and so you can
think of it as being just a method
somehow now the estimator I'm talking
about so that's just the general
Bayesian posterior concentration but you
can also try to understand what is the
property of something that's extracted
from this posterior and one thing that
we actually described was for example
well given this guy maybe it's a good
idea to think about what the mean of
this thing is right so there's gonna be
some theta hat which is just the
integral of theta pi theta given X 1 xn
so that's my posterior D theta right so
that's the posterior mean that's the
expected value with respect to the
posterior distribution and I want to
know how does this thing behave how
close it is to a true theta if I
actually arm if I'm in a frequency setup
so that's the posterior mean but this is
not the only thing I can actually spit
out right this is definitely uniquely
defined if you give me a distribution I
can actually spit out its posterior mean
but I can also think of the posterior
median but now if this is not continuous
you might have some uncertainty maybe
the median is not uniquely defined and
so maybe that's not something you use as
much maybe you can actually talk about
the posterior mode alright so for
example if your posterior density looks
like this then maybe you just want to
summarize your posterior with this
number so clearly in this case it's not
such a good idea because you completely
forget about this mode but maybe that's
what you want to do maybe you want to
focus on the most peak mode and this is
actually called max maximum is a
posterior
as I said you maybe you want to sample
from this posterior distribution okay
and so in all these cases this Bayesian
estimators will depend on the prior
distribution and the hope is that as the
sample size grows you won't see that
again okay so to conclude let's just do
a couple of experiments right so if I
look at did we do this yeah so for
example so let's focus on the posterior
mean and we know so remember in an
experiment one answering the example one
what we had was X 1 X n that were iid
bernal EP and the prior I put on PI on P
was a beta with parameter AAA okay and
if I go back to what we computed you can
actually compute the posterior of this
thing and we know that it's actually
gonna be sorry that was uniform worse
yeah so what we get is that the
posterior this thing is actually going
to be a beta with parameter a plus the
sum so a plus the number of ones and a
plus the number of zeros okay and the
posterior the beta was just something
that looked like the density was P to
the a minus 1 1 minus P
okay so if I want to understand the
posterior mean I need to be able to
compute the expectation of a beta and
then maybe plug in a for a plus this guy
a minus this guy okay so actually let me
do this okay so what is the expectation
so what I want is something that looks
like the integral between 0 and 1 of P
times a minus 1 sorry P times P a minus
1 1 minus P B minus 1 do we agree that
this and then there's a normalizing
constant let's call it C okay so this is
what I need to compute so that's C of a
and B do we agree that this is the
posterior mean with respect to a beta
with parameters a and B right I just
integrate P against the density so what
does this thing look like well I can
actually move this guy in here and here
I'm going to have a plus 1 minus 1 okay
so the problem is that this thing is
actually the constant is going to play a
big role right because this is
essentially equal to C A plus 1 B
divided by C a B where C a plus 1 B is
just the normalizing constant of a beta
ei plus 1 B so I need to know the ratio
of those two constants
and this is not something I mean this is
just a calculus exercise so in this case
what you get is sorry in this case you
get well okay so we get essentially a
divided by I think it's a plus B yeah
it's a plus B so that's this quantity
okay
and when I plug in a to be this guy and
B to be this guy but I get is a plus
some of the X I and then I get a plus
this guy a plus n minus this guy so
those two guys go away and I'm left with
qu a plus n which does not work so ya
know that actually works and so now what
I do I can actually divide and get this
thing over there okay so what you can
see the the reason why this thing has
been divided is that you can really see
that as n goes to infinity then this
thing behaves like xn bar which is our
frequentist estimator the effect of a is
actually going away the effect of the
prior which is completely captured by a
is going away as n goes to infinity is
there any question you guys have a
question what is it
give a question
is it / what oh yeah yeah then I said
that this is equal to this right when so
that's four that's four a becomes a plus
some of the excise and B becomes a plus
n minus some of the excise okay so
that's just for the posterior one this
guy to a right so I get a plus a plus n
and then those two guys cancel okay and
that's what you have here so for a is
equal to one-half and I claim that this
is Jeffrey's prior because remember
Jeffrey's was what well it was square
roots it was proportional to square root
of P one minus P which I can write as P
to the one-half 1 minus P to the
one-half so it's just the case a is
equal to one-half
okay so if I use Jeffrey's prior I just
plug in a equals to 1/2 and this is what
I get
ok so those things are gonna have an
impact again when n is moderately large
for large n those things whether you
take Jeffrey's prior or you take
whatever age you prefer it's gonna have
no impact whatsoever but if n if a if n
is like of the order of 10 maybe then
you're gonna start to see some impact
depending on what a you want to pick
okay and in the in the second example
well here we actually computed the
posterior to be this guy well here I can
just read off what the expectation is
right I mean I don't have to actually
compute the expectation of a Gaussian
it's just X n bar and so in this case
there's actually no I mean when I have
non informative fryer for a Gaussian
then I have basically xn bar and so as
you can see actually this is an
interesting example when I actually look
at the posterior
it's not something that costs me a lot
to communicate to you right there's one
symbol here one symbol here and one
symbol here right I tell you the
posterior is a Gaussian with mean xn bar
and variance 1 over n when I actually
turned that into a posterior mean I'm
dropping all this information I'm just
giving you the first parameter so you
can see there's actually much more
information in the posterior then there
is in the than there is in the posterior
mean the posterior mean is just a point
it's not telling me how confident I am
in this point and this thing is actually
very interesting okay so you can talk
about the posterior variance that's
associated to it right you can talk
about as an output you could give the
posterior mean in the posterior variance
and those things are actually
interesting all right so I think this is
it so as I said in general just like in
this case you do not the choice of the
priors being the the impact of the prior
is being washed away as the sample size
goes to infinity just while I here
there's no impact of the priority with a
non informative one but if you actually
had an informative one you know CF
homework yeah yeah so CF homework you
would actually see an impact of the
prior which again would be washed away
as your sample size increases here it
goes away you just get xn bar over one
and and actually in this cases you see
that the posterior distribution
converges to sorry the Bayesian
estimator is asymptotically normal this
is different from the distribution of
the posterior right this is just the
posterior mean which happens to be
asymptotically normal but the posterior
may not have a I mean here the posterior
is is a beta right I mean it's not
normal
okay so there's different those things
are two different things
your question
a unit on one right that was the
improper prior yeah well I mean yeah so
it's essentially telling you that right
so we said that when you have an
improper when you have a non informative
fryer essentially the maximum likelihood
is the maximum a-posteriori right but in
this case there's so much symmetry that
it just so happens to the maximum I mean
this thing is completely symmetric
around its maximum so it means that the
expectation is equal to maximum 2d art
max yeah but hence do not pick the wrong
prior I mean of course it would I mean
it would mess up to of course I mean
you're putting extra information but you
could say the same thing by saying well
the issue with frequencies methods is
that if you mess up the choice of your
likelihood then it's gonna mess up your
output so here you just have two chances
of messing it up right you have the well
it's going so you have the product of
the likelihood and the end the prior and
you have one more chance to to but it's
true if you assume that the model is
right and of course finding the wrong
prior could completely mess up thing if
your prior for example has no support on
the true parameter but if your prior has
a positive weight on the true parameter
as n goes to infinity you know I mean
okay I cannot speak for all counter
examples in the world but I'm sure under
minor technical conditions you can
guarantee that your posterior mean is
gonna converge to what you needed to
convert to any other question
all right so I think this sort of closes
the more traditional mathematical not
mathematical but you know traditional
statistics part of this class and from
here on we'll talk about more
multivariate statistics starting with
principal component analysis so that's
more like when you have multiple data we
started in a way to talk about
multivariate statistics when we talked
about multivariate regression but we'll
move on to you know principal component
analysis I'll talk a bit about multiple
testing I haven't made my mind yet about
what we'll talk really in December but I
want to make sure that you have a taste
and the flavor of what you know is being
interesting in statistics these days
especially as you go towards more
machine learning type of questions where
really the focus is on prediction rather
than the modeling itself I will talk
about logistic regression as well for
example which is and generalized linear
models which is just the generalization
in the case that Y does not take value
in the whole real line may be 0 1 for
example for regression all right thanks